okay
it's a secret location we could only
film inside but here they planned deadly
attacks on Russian soldiers with
Kamikaze drones
to me they're just kids they're my
children's age but constantly they go to
the front lines of bakmut to launch
their drones Anna is the commander she's
23.
the team are pilots and Engineers they
reprogram the Drone so they disappear on
scanners
then they put them together
that tube is full of high explosive and
unstable
but how do you not get detected I mean
presumably they also have drains drones
looking for you
[Applause]
to all the risks
this is the Kamikaze drone in action
it's launched short of the front lines
they pick individual targets the signal
breaks up
but the observation drone sees its
strike so right now uh Ukrainian tank
you can see it from here but here the
control center watches the back moved
Battlefield in real time these young
tech savvy soldiers are the Seneca unit
of the 93rd Brigade they're so young
they can barely remember life before
Russia's first invasion in 2014. but now
this is a full-on wall
we are fighting for our land for our
history for our culture we are fighting
for our freedom
sovereignty and the fighting for our
people
with a cool sign Miami this boy is just
18. he's from the donbass his father is
fighting here as well the back moved
battle to both of them is an attack on
their actual home
what's it feel like uh uh it's feel very
strange maybe because
not many time ago I walk on the streets
welcome this place it's not about
constantinika only it's about just a VR
uh
it's very strange to see this place in
war
so when we're preparing for the mission
we attach
this way this kind of thing
to the bomb that's not um let's not join
the cables why let's not it's okay no
seriously I don't have the battery in it
so Mark said he joined up as soon as the
Russian invasion started last year he
says he's learned the art of making and
priming the karakazi drone on the job as
it stopped his demonstration was
uncomfortable to witness flying flying
and then we have a Target
and it's attached yeah so we're just
like how's the safety
he like the others watching on say they
have no choice but to fight
it's like uh absurdity of our life
because it's scary and everyone who tell
you this it's not scary it's like
it's scary it's scary to attach the bomb
it's scary to just like land
just like
do all these things but you know your
motivation he knows it's behind you is
just like
nightmare
in reality it is heartbreaking to me
this generation is now at War and
shouldn't be
but then everyone in Ukraine is now
Stu Ramsey Sky News eastern Ukraine